it has been confirmed that there are two
cases now in England this is a statement
from Professor Chris Witte who's the
chief of medical officer for England he
said we can confirm that two patients in
England who are members of the same
family have tested positive for
coronavirus the patients are receiving
specialist NHS care and we are using
tried and tested infection control
procedures to prevent further spread of
the virus the NHS is extremely well
prepared and used to managing infections
and we are already working rapidly to
identify any contacts the patient's had
to prevent further spread we have been
preparing for UK cases of novel
coronavirus and we have robust infection
control measures in place to respond
immediately we are continuing to work
closely with the World Health
Organization and the international
community as the outbreak in China
develops to ensure that we are ready for
all eventualities so Chris Witte the
chief medical officer for England
confirming two cases have now been
identified in this country that follows
cases in France and Germany and
elsewhere